io ok ragazzi prima di cominciare però
soltanto dirvi una cosa giuro faccio
velocissimo voglio dirvi st premessa
perché il gioco che state per vedere
lost saga che uno dei pochissimi giochi
online che ho fatto finora e siccome
ragazzi vi è piaciuto abbastanza voglio
provare a farci una live nel quale lo
gioco con voi nella stessa partita
giocheremo insieme per chi vuole
partecipare ovviamente ma che mi
costringo col coltello però se volete
primi tre ragazzi voglio fare la live il
set di maggiolini la settimana prossima
se volete partecipare a giocare con me
perché comunque faremo partire insieme
stavolta organizzato molto meglio per
questo gioco sembra decente per chiunque
vorrà partecipare lascio il link qui
sotto in descrizione qui se volete già
scaricarlo siete già pronti e niente se
volete partecipare il link quello
comunque lo dico poi nel blog meglio la
foresta premessa concave ragazzi non
importa ci vediamo a adesso è la tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su dell'host
saga che è un videogioco un po strano
dato che stamattina non ho fatto video
volevo uscire apparendo e lo so che se
ti incazzati neri che lo riuscire a fare
un gioco che fosse tranquillo cos'è sta
roba è limitato a una partita sì sì ma
gli unici di un incipit è una cosa mai
così la partita è allora che cazzo mi
invitate
abbiamo iniziato di merda perché non
serve avere ovviamente ragazzi associamo
consisterebbe nel riuscire a fare una
partita contro day cioè una cosa stupida
hai rotto il cazzo tanto non mi entrano
e partite inutili ma non mi entra
perfetto può avere un detto mi entra chi
sono io so che io io sono sono il
cavaliere miga
e cos'è sta roba che via via così via
con non so neanche come cazzo si si
muove ma non importa andiamo che gli
echi sono questo bellissimo dichiarare
io vendo rose nel metrò ma di obi
comparto nell'arena ragazzi sta cosa mi
mi piace un casino anche se non capito
tutto
ragazze questo mi ha colpito soprattutto
pezzo di merda no ragazzi allora mi devo
capire come ci si muove perché tram si
dice che fa in cui la fa vj che fai
pooling il culo da 30v contro un'altra
persona con la dimessa vaglia volete
perso a prescindere no perché io vendo
rosee per il lancio addosso sono morto
l'affetto ragazza ho capito subito come
joe chiamata tra cui sono in due allora
se l'è stronzi bastardi
ma che poi la cosa bella di suo gioco
ragazzi che essendo online posso cristo
la reed avvero sulla gente che chicche
[ __ ] di posti strano allora
avete rotto il cazzo mi sta scoprendo
con un martello devi morire mi sembra
mi sembra un orgia una cosa leggere
ragazzi cosa cazzo stato ceco me ci si
muove ecco perché non faccio il genere i
giochi costello perché c'è un palloncino
nel culo ok ve l'avevo detto che sta
roba non aveva senso le gambe che
effetto mi state stuprando da mezz'ora
la volete finire come steve e goffa vj
korsakov a vijay che sono in due cazzo
dammi la mano invece di scrivere no
niente
santissima allora scappiamo di qua
perché mi sta allora facciamo così
vi porto un mazzo di rose tanto e poi
son cazzi vostri
ancora non ho capito che cosa devo fare
a parte fare il culo asi stronzi soca
non so se ti è chiaro sento il duetto
[ __ ] commento ragazzi sono diventate una
cazzo di sottiletta avete capito il
fatto che dovete morire non so che
rientra in testa sta cosa niente mi
buttano ragazzi sono in due ragon bolt
mi ha insegnato che nella vita io posso
farcela anche da sel sono morto porca
[ __ ]
ragazzi non sa se io non so cosa fa
[Musica]
alimentato una nuova danza cazzo ma ecco
questo è meglio di danza kuduro e cioè
allora [ __ ]
morì tu non puoi non puoi competere con
il passo di lancio stronzi merda
dobbiamo morire gravi morire
niente mistura bravi bravi bravi bravi
aver bravi che perché è bello che sei
veramente un figo e non te lo volevo
dire ma sei è un pivot kruger e
assisterà salmone e divertente siccome
giocata per chi non sa giocare anni fa
adesso adesso siamo noi in due bastardo
che sudi scopriamo come non so ma tipo
che te l'ho messo alcun tono sono
diventato il boss di soggiorno ormai
sono troppo e nelle classifiche per
quello che ho fatto lo so perché tutti
amiamo bastardo chi per dato il permesso
di toccare must tardi ma vieni qui miei
amici dove vai dove cazzo vai ragazzi
questo scappa a questo è stronzo si no
ma mi chiedo è rimasto anche lui rimasto
non è caduti monetali no e non è mica mi
incazzo giuro sono ancora mi chiama
buttato giù non ci siamo buttati giù non
so come non è possibile
devi andare devi andare gioco devi
andare giù non va giù non è giusto che
impossibile siamo a un millimetro da da
un burrone norme e non va giù è una cosa
pazzesca riano non ha senso bene
passando da ragazzino
va bene niente e poi l'elemento sei
piedi porca [ __ ] un vano non c'è verso
dammi la mano capitan uncino dei miei
[ __ ] fai qualcosa ma che sta
combattendo da solo mio dio ci fa il
culo su quello della vittoria
[Musica]
e dopo tutto sto casino dove cazzo
saremmo finiti di preciso che ancora non
sei ancora qui ragazzi ancora non si sa
come ma è ancora vivo solo tronto ci
vieni due chiame
sapete perché scappata cup ora di
prenderlo nei cup ranzi ma lo ha preso
lo stesso a me fama soldi e belle donne
ragazzi ho vinto ho vinto la partita più
importante nella mia vita dopo questo
sono diventate un loro completo
all'inizio infatti mi ci vedete c'è
qualcos'altro perché ci sembra la stessa
da un po non peccato bisogna fare
qualcosa di decente
ecco perche come quello ragazzi vediamo
se si può fare qualcosa di te ecco la fa
questo del boss
ho cambiato ragazzi ho cambiato colore
perché ovviamente gli stessi sempre con
le stesse mutande non fa mai bene chi
cazzo pesce robin hood ragazzi c'è gente
ragazzi c'è già il suo importante perché
c'è gente muta è si è suicidato perché
ovviamente c'era le mutande talmente
brutta che se non gli piace è stato poi
questa cosa non sono anche corpo che c'è
un tipo che sto picchiando un tizio e
mutande il ragazzo siamo razzisti conti
con i tizi in mutande non so perché il
ragazzo ufficio che conosco quanto dieci
volte me ma io sono stato ucciso non vi
si muta questa è l'ambizione della mia
vita cioè sancisi dà notizia in mutande
ragazzi ho notato che il morto non ho
notato che sono il nero con dei capelli
che che sembra un leonardo di caprio e
non so perché
che poi grazie ancora non classificato e
la visuale film cioè i primi tempi è
come se comanda sentito in un film era
una volta ragazzi leonardo di caprio con
i capelli biondi ne incontrarla vinoodh
a caso il rapper delle arene e riuscì a
vincere la battaglia sono sanzione
sono morto ha vinto l'oscar sofil due
ragazzi programma a fare tipo che in
questa che vanno a fare il culo agli
spagnoli perché la partita spagnola di
nuovo i sostituti colorati mi ricordano
cubo di gala [ __ ]
io tendo rosa vendo cielo fabbriche mi
sono salvato per la
alenia per laconico si raccoglie questo
l'accordo ragazzi ho trovato un cappello
ho trovato ho trovato dell'arco sinistra
notato della dinamica allora devi morire
stronzo di merda ho trovato della
dinamica anche se non hai capito di cosa
farmene chiama cielo questa norma
ragazzi trovano per terra non so perché
ma non importa
devi morire allora vede scappare
qualcosa di decente la partita ci sia
tipo no notte se sì ma [ __ ] è
rimasta niente non capita se fuori non
muore non muore non muore non muore si è
in mutande è in mutande non so perché
l'ho ucciso lucido ucciso ma sono molto
da bere almeno almeno facciamo uno per
uno perché non è possibile
ok miracolo che sia uscita fare saltano
ragazzino provare a fare il culo
l'ultima volta sti tizi e poi giuro che
c'è un po poiché stava allora devi
morire il bastardo allora ma ce l'hai
con me no no perche sto ammirando a me
porca [ __ ] conto di quelli che ci sono
allora adesso e ti vengo a prendere a
calci ventenni spariti santi che minchia
no no ci si chiedeva che il suo fatto e
allora sì basta attacchi la gente a
terra sei un vigliacco vigliacco di
merda dove scappi strapieni qui vieni
qui non è che se soft marmori stronzo
muori kakà è ancora è ancora vivo già
ancora che cosa sta succedendo una cosa
sono morto
va bene quando vincono socialista faccia
dai [ __ ]
perché ora rialzi faccio un ultimo se
riesco perché ormai sono riuscito a fare
uscire subito per milano quindi non so
se riesco a pubblicarlo fatto cosa la
più veloce che riuscivo perché non
potevo ragazzi quando non riesco a
registrare video o faccio ste cose alla
velocissima pure aspetto domani perché è
impossibile
comunque voglio fare il culo a qualcuno
nell'ultima questa sicuro perché ci sono
le le le scale tecniche miste o vi
stanno uccidendo ancora son partito
siete in tre ma io non temo nessuno io
non temo nessuno allora vinifera stato
beni che va a fan culo
dove hai lasciato il paracadute a casa
zio sta diventando un fenomeno non c'è
più non c'è non c'è verso c'è una roba
sono un cazzo di demente che va beh
l'ultima scena l'ultima sera
probabilmente la taglio poiché non so se
ho fatto un pò la figura di me ma non
importa tanto sono bravissimo lo sapete
nasconde vitro che nasconde che non è
proprio paura di perdere uno giorni ma
non cadono ancora quel caso di cowboy
non è così no che a [ __ ] guai se si no
è caduto è rimasto in mutande ma non è
il caso ma come cazzo è possibile che
questi stronzi nella minaccia bello
proprio io non ci trovo un senso a tutto
questo ma non c'è una spada tra l'altro
l'ho trovato a terra di chi cazzo è non
lo so ma devi morire voglio una ferrari
per premium cazzo io mi sento mia
il fenomeno quando quando muoio in
mutande ma non si sposta per e karachi
ed infatti lo sapremo ragazzi io io
lascerei il venditore di rose al suo
triste destino
ecco che concluderei quell'episodio
conca ragazzi usate miss oggi non ho
fatto video nel pomeriggio ma perché c'è
un casino da fare non mi vedo se riesco
a recuperare
scusatemi se ho fatto una rovina la
veloce ma dovevo riuscire a fare
qualcosa perché era un due geni che non
registra uno stop non preoccupato i
ragazzi comunque io a dire che possono
chiudere qui cosa ragazzi seguito è
piaciuto sotto il commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e konami
video trovate la descrizione sensi
travestiti iscrivetevi riuscirete ad un
prossimo video belle ragazze